From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And I am joined in the studio right now by one of my co-workers, Aviva DeKornfeld.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。此时此刻，我的同事阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德也来到了录音室。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
Hi, there. And so you're here to tell us a story.
你好。你今天来是想给我们讲个故事，对吧？
Yes. It happened probably when I was 11 or 12. I was with my older sister, Ora, who's probably 14, and our cousin, Jake, who's 16 or so. He was visiting us. And one night we decided it would be fun to sneak into the community pool, which is just a few blocks away from our house.
是的。这件事大概发生在我11或12岁的时候。当时我和大我大概14岁的姐姐奥拉，以及16岁左右的表哥杰克在一起，他当时来我们家做客。一天晚上，我们决定潜入离家只有几个街区的社区游泳池，觉得那样会很刺激。
The community pool was closed?
社区游泳池关门了吗？
Yes. It's probably midnight. Our parents are asleep. We'd never snuck in. So we're walking to the pool. And I actually didn't even want to sneak into the pool. I was scared, but I just-- the bliss of being included with the older kids as the younger one very much overrode my reservations.
是的，当时大概是午夜，父母都睡着了。我们以前从没潜入过。我们走去泳池的路上，其实我根本不想进去。我很害怕，但我被那种身为小辈能加入大孩子队伍的快乐冲昏了头脑，完全盖过了我的顾虑。
Absolutely.
当然。
So we get to the pool, scale the chain link fence, hop over, triumphant. Immediately, like one second after we've entered the pool, sirens go off. They're so loud. It's like, woo-woo. And then an automated voice comes on, and it's like, you are trespassing. The police have been alerted. They're on their way. Evacuate the premises.
我们到了泳池，爬过铁丝网，翻了进去，感觉很成功。可就在我们进去的一秒钟后，警报器响了，声音大得惊人，呜呜地叫着。接着传来一个自动语音说：“你们正在非法入侵。警方已接到通知，正在赶往现场。请立即撤离。”
Right. And you guys are children, so--
没错。而你们当时还是孩子，所以……
So we panic. And my cousin, he is the oldest and tallest. And he just runs to the fence, hops over it, clears it no problem, takes off running. And then my sister is next. And she hops up on the fence, but then she kind of falls down. She doesn't quite make it over.
所以我们慌了。我表哥是年纪最大、个子最高的。他跑向围栏，轻松翻了过去，然后撒腿就跑。接着是我姐姐，她爬上围栏，却又不小心滑了下来，没能翻过去。
And then she hops up again, and she was just moving so slowly, in my mind. It was probably 15 seconds, actually. And what I did in my panic, is, she was up about 2 feet off the ground, holding on to the fence. And I grabbed her waist, and I ripped her off the fence. And I climbed over myself.
然后她又爬上去，但在我看来，她的动作慢得要命。实际上大概过了15秒。在惊慌失措下，我抓住了她的腰，把她从围栏上硬拽了下来，然后自己爬了过去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I-- And it's the w-- we get home. She's fine. She eventually makes it over. But for me, this is the first moment that I remember thinking, I have been shown what kind of person I am, and I am a very bad person. Or there is a part of me that is deeply selfish or capable of deep selfishness.
后来……我们回到家，她也没事，最终也翻过来了。但对我来说，这是我第一次意识到：我看到了自己是个什么样的人，我是一个非常糟糕的人。或者说，我的内心深处有一种极度自私，或者说有着深厚自私潜质的部分。
Yeah. That's like a very grown-up thought to have. And there comes a time when you think that for the first time, right, you're 11, and you're capable of that.
是啊，这是一个非常成熟的想法。每个人都有第一次产生这种想法的时刻，对吧，当你才11岁却具备了这种潜能。
Yeah. And what I saw was, this is who you are. You're the kind of person who prioritizes yourself over other people, including the person you love the most. My big sister was the person I idolized at the time, and we're still very close. But I was really like, anything for you. I love you so much. And then it turns out, actually, nope, I just want to save myself when I'm scared.
是的。我所看到的是：你就是这样的人。你是那种会把自己看得比别人重要的人，哪怕对方是你最爱的人。当时我非常崇拜我的姐姐，我们现在依然很亲近。我当时心想“为了你我什么都愿意做”，我那么爱你。结果却发现，不对，当我感到恐惧时，我只想拯救自己。
And the whole reason I'm here telling you this story is because I think that lots of people have moments like this and that these moments can act as a kind of mirror that reflect something back at you about yourself.
我今天之所以在这里讲这个故事，是因为我觉得很多人都有过这样的时刻，这些时刻就像一面镜子，照出了你自己内心的某种东西。
And does this moment come back to you in the years since?
这些年来，这一幕还会时不时浮现在你脑海吗？
Absolutely. Every time I do something a little selfish or say something kind of shitty, or just, like, I have some sort of failure of kindness, I think back to this moment, and I'm like, well, that's the real you.
绝对会。每当我做了一些稍微自私的事，或者说了什么糟糕的话，哪怕只是表现出一点点不够善良，我都会想起那一刻，心想：瞧，这才是真正的你。
Wow. OK, so the reason you're telling this story, I know, is that you have come here today with a collection of stories and moments like this one from a variety of people.
哇。好吧，我知道你讲这个故事的原因，是因为你今天带来了一系列来自不同人的、类似这样的故事和时刻。
Yeah.
是的。
And with that, I'm going to just step out of the way and just hand over the show to you to host.
那么，我就先退到一边，把节目的主持权交给你。
OK. Wait. Should I say, "I'm Aviva DeKornfeld sitting in for Ira Glass," or no?
好的。等一下，我是不是该说“我是代班主持艾拉·格拉斯的阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德”，还是不用？
No, no, you don't have to do that because I think everybody's gotten that by this point.
不用，不用，因为我觉得大家到现在都已经知道了。
They know who's who?
他们知道谁是谁吗？
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑声] 知道。
OK. [LAUGHS]
好吧。[笑声]
They have the cast of characters.
他们已经熟悉了角色阵容。
OK. Today on the show, we have stories, like mine, about people who are suddenly confronted with a part of themselves they had not previously known and how they deal with that newfound knowledge. Stay with us.
好的。今天的节目里，我们有一些故事，就像我的经历一样，讲述人们突然面对自己此前从未了解过的一面，以及他们如何处理这些新获得的认知。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, On Top of Spaghetti, All Covered With Shame. So that moment with my sister when I was 11, did it change me? I can tell you that I have never pulled her, or anyone, off a fence while running from the police again, not even once. But beyond that, no. I think this moment gave me a little window into myself, and that's about it. Fundamentally, I am the same person.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，意大利面上的羞耻感。那么，11岁时我把姐姐拽下围栏的那一刻，改变了我吗？我可以告诉你，此后我再也没有在躲避警察时把她或者任何人从围栏上拽下来过，一次都没有。但除此之外，并没有。我觉得那一刻只是给了我一扇窥视内心的窗户，仅此而已。从根本上说，我还是同一个人。
My coworker, Tobin Low, when I told him this story, he was like, well, yeah, I'm sure most people who have these split-second moments of selfishness don't really change. And to that, I say, what kind of world is that? Not one I want to live in. So I sent Tobin searching to see if he could find someone who had one of these moments and actually did change. I'll let Tobin take it from here.
当我把这个故事告诉我的同事托宾·洛时，他说：“好吧，确实，我相信大多数有过这种瞬间自私时刻的人都不会真正改变。”对此，我说，那是一个什么样的世界？那不是我想居住的世界。所以我派托宾去寻找，看看能否找到一个经历过这种时刻并且真的发生了改变的人。接下来交给托宾。
David and his girlfriend were fast asleep in his apartment in London when someone started banging on the door downstairs, screaming, fire. He got up and opened the bedroom door to find smoke piling in. And here is where he had his moment of split-second decision-making.
大卫和他的女友当时正在伦敦的公寓里熟睡，突然有人在楼下狂敲门大喊“着火了”。他起床打开卧室门，发现浓烟滚滚涌入。就在这一刻，他做出了瞬间的决策。
My first reaction was, OK, self-preservation. I'm going to get my passport because if that burns up, I'm going to be stuck here. I'm going to get my trousers because, again, I don't want to look foolish waiting downstairs in my underwear. And then I got my shoes. I ran outside. And I ran so vigorously, I ran up against a wall, and I got a burn, like a carpet burn, but from the wall. And I really wanted to get out of there.
我的第一反应是：好吧，保命要紧。我要去拿护照，如果它烧没了，我就被困在这儿了。我要拿裤子，因为我不想穿着内裤站在楼下显得很傻。然后我拿了鞋子。我跑了出去，跑得太猛，直接撞在墙上，磨掉了一层皮，就像地毯烧伤一样，不过是在墙上磨出来的。我当时真的很想逃出去。
He made it outside. And it occurred to him only then that his girlfriend existed, and she'd also been in that smoke-filled room that he'd fled, passport in hand. He realized this because she was standing next to him. She'd made it out, too. But he had to admit to himself--
他跑到了外面，这时才想起还有个女朋友，她也待在那间被浓烟覆盖的屋子里，而他自己却手握护照逃了出来。他意识到这一点，是因为她就站在他身边。她也逃出来了。但他不得不向自己承认——
Oh, I'm glad she's safe, obviously, but I didn't have anything to do with that.
噢，我当然很高兴她平安无事，但我对此一点功劳都没有。
His girlfriend, who's now his wife, says, I'm pretty sure I ran out ahead of you. He doesn't buy that, still beats himself up, says it's like a cloud of shame that follows him around. And yet--
他现在的妻子当时说：“我敢肯定是我先跑出来的。”他不相信这一点，至今仍自责不已，说这就像一层挥之不去的羞耻云团。然而——
Do you think it caused you to be the kind of person who runs towards a fire now? Do you think you're more of that person now?
你觉得那次经历让你变成了一个现在会冲向火场的人吗？你觉得你现在更像那样的人吗？
I think no. I think I'm definitely-- I don't think I'm a hero.
我觉得没有。我觉得我绝对……我不认为自己是个英雄。
I put the call out in multiple places, talked to everyone I knew, wondering if I'd find a kind of superhero origin story, someone who took their pain and turned it into action. Turns out, there are many people out there haunted by the ghosts of split-second decisions past.
我在多处发布了征集信息，询问了认识的每一个人，想知道能不能找到某种“超级英雄起源故事”，那种将痛苦转化为行动的人。结果发现，有许多人都被过去那一瞬间决策的阴影所困扰。
Jonah in Illinois-- one night, his girlfriend woke up with terrible food poisoning from eating a bison Sloppy Joe. She was suddenly and violently throwing up. He said he thought of helping, but instead, snatched the blanket off of her, threw it over his head, and ran out of the room. He said the smell was too terrible.
伊利诺伊州的乔纳，一天晚上，他女友因为吃了野牛肉馅饼食物中毒，突然剧烈呕吐。他说他本想帮忙，结果却一把扯过毯子蒙住头，跑出了房间。他说味道实在太恶心了。
Did it change you in some way?
这件事以某种方式改变你了吗？
Um, no. No, I would say no. But I was a bit embarrassed, like ashamed that I didn't step up to the plate a little bit better. In my defense, it was extremely, extremely gross.
嗯，没有。不，我会说没有。但我确实有点尴尬，感到羞愧，因为我没能表现得更好一点。为自己辩解一下，那真的非常、非常恶心。
To be fair to Jonah, I don't know that I would have stuck around for a repeat appearance of bison Sloppy Joes either, though there was a small pattern developing in my search results, a recurring theme of boyfriends making the, quote unquote, "wrong" decision, but not doing much differently afterwards. I wish I could report that it's going to change from here on out, but here we go.
平心而论，乔纳，我不知道如果野牛肉馅饼再出现一次，我是不是也能坚持住。尽管在我的搜集结果中确实出现了一个小模式——反复出现的都是男友做出了所谓的“错误”选择，但在那之后并没有做出多大改变。我真希望我能说这会从今往后有所改观，但事实就是这样。
A lot of times, it was the girlfriends who wrote in to tell us what happened. There's Jana, who lived in bear country. One afternoon, a black bear charged. And what did her boyfriend do? He ran for his life, leaving Jana to fend for herself.
很多时候，写信告诉我们发生了什么的都是女性。比如住在熊出没地区的珍娜。一天下午，一只黑熊冲了过来，而她男友做了什么？他为了逃命跑掉了，把珍娜留在那儿自生自灭。
A similar thing happened to another woman, but instead of a bear, it was a charging bull. When she turned to grab her boyfriend's hand, she discovered he was already long gone, racing to the car.
另一位女士也发生了类似的事情，不过对方不是熊，是一头冲过来的公牛。当她转身想抓住男友的手时，却发现他早已不见踪影，直奔车子去了。
Jenny in North Carolina-- she and her high school boyfriend were sneaking back into her house after curfew. Her stepdad thought it was an intruder and pulled a gun on them. What did her boyfriend do? He yanked her in front of him, used her as a human shield.
北卡罗来纳州的珍妮，她和高中男友在宵禁后偷偷潜回她家。她继父以为家里进了贼，拔枪对着他们。她男友做了什么？他把她拉到身前，把她当成了肉盾。
Did you dump that guy right after it happened?
事情发生后你就把那家伙甩了吗？
Oh, absolutely not. No.
噢，绝对没有。没甩。
They stayed together for five more years. And surprise, surprise, he was a jerk the whole time.
他们又在一起待了五年。惊喜的是，在那期间他一直是个混蛋。
It ended very tragically and heartbroken for me, which is funny looking back on it, because it was like, he was a really bad boyfriend.
结局非常惨烈，我也很伤心，回想起来觉得很有趣，因为他真的是个很烂的男朋友。
Talking to all these people, my search was coming up empty. Nobody seemed to be changing their behavior. They felt guilt, shame, embarrassment, sure, but actually changing? Not so much.
跟这些人聊过之后，我的调查一无所获。似乎没人改变自己的行为。他们感到内疚、羞耻、尴尬，当然，但真正改变吗？并没有。
Then I talked to Becca. Becca is a pharmacist who lives in Chicago. Her story happened while she was on a medical mission trip in Ethiopia. Her and her team were there working at a local clinic.
然后我跟贝卡聊了聊。贝卡是芝加哥的一名药剂师。她的故事发生在埃塞俄比亚的一次医疗援助旅行中。当时她和团队在当地一家诊所工作。
It was the end of her stint. She was headed back to the airport from the village she had been working in. There was Becca, a paramedic, and this older volunteer couple, Frank and Sue. Before their flight, they sit down for a meal at a restaurant. They're starving. Everyone else gets burgers. Becca orders a plate of spaghetti.
任务快结束了，她正准备从工作的村庄返回机场。同行的有贝卡、一名急救护理人员，还有一对老志愿者夫妇，弗兰克和苏。登机前，他们在一家餐馆坐下来吃饭。大家都饿坏了，别人都点了汉堡，贝卡点了一盘意大利面。
And Frank just becomes unresponsive a little bit at the table. He didn't faint. He just was sitting there, staring into space and breathing heavily. And I just thought he was dehydrated. And I was like, Frank, here, drink this. Our food's here, and I'm so excited to eat. And then he's not responding to his wife. She's like, Frank, Frank. And he's just sitting there, labored breathing.
弗兰克坐在桌边突然没了反应。他没晕倒，只是坐在那儿，双眼无神，呼吸沉重。我以为他只是脱水了，就说：“弗兰克，喝点这个。”我们的饭到了，我正兴奋地准备吃。接着他对妻子的呼唤毫无反应。她说：“弗兰克，弗兰克。”他只是坐着，呼吸艰难。
Frank falls out of his chair, fully passes out.
弗兰克从椅子上摔了下来，彻底昏迷了。
And then the paramedic immediately jumps up, this huge, I don't know-- 6' 5", bulky guy, and he just throws him over his shoulder and starts running back towards the van and is like, come on, we're finding a hospital. And his wife is confused, but she's following and just like, uh, OK, what's going on? Is Frank going to be OK? Like, just frantic.
那个急救员立刻跳了起来，个子很高大，有一米九五左右，他直接把弗兰克扛在肩上就往面包车方向跑，边喊：“快，我们去找医院。”他妻子很困惑，但还是跟了上去，非常慌乱地问：“弗兰克会没事吗？”
And I-- oh, this is so bad. I sat at that table like an idiot, trying to get the wait staff's attention to see if we can get to-go boxes for the food. And Cornell, the paramedic, is yelling, let's go. We have to go. I stand up, and I pick up my plate of spaghetti carbonara on a white porcelain plate with silverware, and take that with me into the van.
然后我……噢，这太糟糕了。我像个白痴一样坐在餐桌旁，试图引起服务员的注意，看能不能把我们的饭打包。那个急救员康奈尔在喊：“快走，必须得走。”我站起来，拿起了我那盘意式培根蛋酱面，端着那盘白瓷盘子和餐具，就这样带进了车里。
So we're zooming away. Frank's in the back seat, for all we know, dying. And I'm holding this plate of spaghetti in the car.
车子飞驰而去。弗兰克躺在后座，在我们看来可能快不行了。而我还在车里端着那盘意大利面。
I talked to Cornell, the paramedic. He said, yes, he remembers her holding the plate of spaghetti while he performed CPR on Frank the entire ride to the hospital, and also feeling kind of like, OK, I guess I'm on my own here.
我采访了急救员康奈尔。他说他记得她在去医院的路上一直端着那盘面，而在他全程给弗兰克做心肺复苏时，他心里觉得：“好吧，看来我只能靠自己了。”
And I don't know why I did it. I don't know why I did it. I don't know why I did it. I was immediately so ashamed and so embarrassed.
我不知道我为什么要那么做。我不知道，我真的不知道。我立刻感到非常羞耻和尴尬。
When did you eventually put the plate of spaghetti down?
你最终是什么时候放下那盘意大利面的？
[SIGHS] When we got to a hospital. And I put this plate of spaghetti just on the seat, in the van, and we all went inside.
[叹气] 到了医院之后。我把盘子放在面包车座椅上，我们就都进去了。
Frank ended up being OK. They hooked him up to an IV. He felt better after a couple of hours. They got back in the van to head to the airport. And dear listener, if you're wondering if the plate of spaghetti was still there, if the driver of the van handed it back to Becca like a trophy of shame, if it sat on her lap because she was too ashamed to eat it in front of everyone else, yes, that did happen. Afterward, they joked that she was just looking out for them. She was just bringing them a snack.
弗兰克最终没事了。医生给他挂了点滴，几个小时后他就感觉好多了。他们又回到车上准备去机场。亲爱的听众，如果你想知道那盘面还在不在，司机有没有把它像战利品一样递回给贝卡，或者它是不是一直放在她腿上因为她太羞愧不敢当着大家的面吃掉——是的，确实发生了。事后，他们开玩笑说她其实是在照顾大家，带了点零食。
What do you think was actually happening in your head at that moment?
你觉得在那一刻你脑子里到底在想什么？
I think I was hungry and I wanted spaghetti. I think I was being really selfish. I really do. I think I was being really selfish. It doesn't sound good, right, when I say it.
我觉得我当时饿了，想吃意大利面。我觉得我当时真的非常自私。真的。我觉得我非常自私。这话听起来很糟糕，对吧？
To me, it sounds like someone who went into shock. And you don't make rational choices when you're in shock.
我觉得那是一个陷入休克的人。人在休克时是无法做出理性选择的。
But everyone else did. I think that's what still gets me. And I have since almost swung the other direction of trying to be so selfless. Just the other day, this woman fell in the middle of the road at the airport, blood everywhere. I drop all my stuff, run over there. I don't care about my luggage. I don't care about my stuff. Someone can steal my phone. I don't care. I need to help this person.
但其他人都做出了选择。我觉得那才是让我耿耿于怀的地方。从那以后，我几乎走向了另一个极端，试图表现得无私。就在前几天，一个女人在机场路上摔倒了，到处都是血。我扔下所有行李跑过去。我不在乎我的行李，不在乎我的东西。有人偷走手机也无所谓。我必须帮助这个人。
She's really trying to change. There are other examples. Like last year, when she was driving on the highway, when she saw a car accident, someone flung from their vehicle, she immediately pulled over, left her keys in the ignition, her dog in the back seat, just trying to get to this person to help. Becca is the only person I talked to who actually lives her life differently after reflecting on how she acted.
她真的在尝试改变。还有其他例子，比如去年她在高速公路上开车看到一起车祸，有人被甩出车外，她立即靠边停车，把车钥匙留在点火开关上，把狗留在后座，一心只想去救那个人。贝卡是我采访过的人中，唯一一个在反思自己的行为后，真的开始以不同方式生活的人。
I'm trying to use that in a positive way, I think, now, because it's pretty gross, what I did.
我想，我现在正在尝试以一种积极的方式来运用这种反思，因为我当时的行为真的太恶心了。
Do you think each time you're doing something like that, are you thinking about that plate of spaghetti on some level?
你觉得每次你做那种事情的时候，某种程度上是否会想到那盘意大利面？
Honestly, I think maybe I am, somewhere in the recesses of my mind, yes.
老实说，我想可能吧，在内心深处的某个角落，是的。
I think we're tempted to think of these moments of panic as revealing our true nature. But really, that's just the animal part of your brain reacting on instinct. The stuff we do after those moments, when we apologize, or double down, or gaslight, or atone, that's the part that makes us human.
我认为我们总是倾向于认为这些恐慌时刻暴露了我们的本性。但实际上，那只是你大脑中动物性的本能反应。而在那些时刻之后，当我们道歉、变本加厉、推卸责任或赎罪时，那才是让我们之所以成为人的部分。
Tobin Low, he's an editor at our show.
托宾·洛，我们节目的编辑。
Act Two, BWE, Big Wig Energy. You know those moments in life where everything's falling apart, and it feels like you're drowning? You've gone through a breakup. You've been laid off. And so you just grab on to the first log you see floating down the river, just so you have something to hold on to, like a rebound relationship or some new hobby you get way too invested in.
第二幕，大佬气质。你知道生活中那些一切分崩离析、感觉自己快要溺水的时刻吗？你失恋了，被解雇了。于是你抓住了河里漂过的第一根圆木，只是为了有个东西可以依靠，比如一段反弹式的恋情，或者某种你投入太多的新爱好。
That's what Leisha did, which led her to trying on this whole new identity. It began when Leisha's best friend adopted a dog, and Leisha decided to buy a present to celebrate. Leisha's best friend is a hardcore Pittsburgh Steelers fan, so she decides to buy the dog a Troy Polamalu jersey. Troy was her friend's favorite player on the team, known for, among other things, his long, curly hair. Leisha finds a dog jersey, no problem.
莉莎就是这样做的，这导致她尝试了全新的身份。起因是莉莎最好的朋友领养了一只狗，莉莎决定买件礼物庆祝。她朋友是匹兹堡钢人队的死忠粉，所以她决定给狗买一件特洛伊·波拉马鲁的球衣。特洛伊是她朋友最喜欢的队员，标志性特征之一就是他那头又长又卷的头发。莉莎很容易就买到了球衣。
And I thought, oh, this would be great. I'll get the wig to go with this jersey. I went to all the pet stores. I looked online. And I could not find a wig. And I thought, well, this is like a void that needs to be filled. And I decided I was going to be the one to do it.
我想，噢，太棒了，我要买顶假发来搭配这件球衣。我跑遍了宠物店，也在网上查过，但怎么也找不到假发。于是我想，这真是一个亟待填补的空白，而我决定成为填补它的人。
These days, pet wigs are everywhere. You can order one with next-day shipping. But this was back in the primitive days of 2014, before our culture had advanced quite that far. Leisha is good at lots of things. She's a musician and actress. You might recognize her from The L Word. But none of that translated to knowing how to make a hairpiece for a dog.
现在，宠物假发随处可见，网上下单第二天就能送到。但那是在2014年的原始时代，文化还没进步到那个程度。莉莎什么都擅长，她是音乐家也是演员，你可能在《拉字至上》里见过她。但这并不意味着她知道怎么给狗做假发。
Fortunately, her sister is a hairdresser. So together, they bought a bunch of Styrofoam balls in three different sizes to represent the heads of small, medium, and large dogs. Then they bought some cheap wigs for humans to cut up and turn into prototypes. They came up with 10 different iconic hairstyles from throughout history. They made a mullet, a B52-style beehive, a gray Golden Girls wig.
幸运的是，她姐姐是美发师。所以她们买了一堆不同大小的泡沫球，代表小型、中型和大型犬的头部。然后买了些便宜的人类假发，剪碎做成原型。她们一共设计了10种历史上最具标志性的发型。她们做了鲻鱼头、B52乐队式的蜂窝头、《黄金女郎》风格的灰色假发。
I had a Farrah Fawcett long, blonde flowing hair, feathered. I had a bob, like, "can I see the manager" kind of bob.
我还做了法拉·福塞特那种长长的金发，带羽毛状的。还有鲍勃头，就是那种“我要见你们经理”风格的短发。
What's your favorite wig that you made?
你最喜欢的一顶是哪个？
I think, for me, it was the beehive because it was so-- it was just the ultimate wig. It was fire-red. It had little sideburns that were curled, that came down. And it got funnier as it got smaller. It made a lot of sense on a pitbull, but when it went down to a chihuahua or a Pomeranian, it was hilarious. I think that was a big part of this, is that it was so silly and so joyful. It was enjoyable to wake up and think about. And that's a really nice thing to follow.
我想对我来说是蜂窝头，因为它太极致了。它是火红色的，还有卷曲的鬓角垂下来。它越小就越滑稽。戴在比特犬头上很合理，但换成吉娃娃或博美犬时就太搞笑了。我认为这很关键，因为它真的很傻、很快乐。每天醒来想到它都觉得很有趣。那是一个非常棒的目标。
Leisha had had a really rough year before this. Her mom got sick. Then she went through a big breakup. Then she left the band she'd been in for the better part of 10 years, which meant she was also out of work. But now she had a mission. Leisha went all in on the pet wigs. Over the next few months, Leisha and her sister make 30 wigs, all 10 designs in each of the three sizes. She also got an LLC, opened a bank account. Of course, she needed a name for her product. She decided to keep it simple-- PetWigs, one word.
在做这个之前，莉莎那一年过得很惨。妈妈生病了，接着她经历了一场大分手，然后离开了待了近十年的乐队，意味着她也失业了。但现在她有了使命。莉莎全身心投入到宠物假发中。接下来的几个月里，莉莎和她姐姐做了30顶假发，涵盖了所有10种设计和三种尺寸。她还注册了有限责任公司，开了银行账户。当然，她需要给产品起个名字。她决定简单点——PetWigs，合二为一。
I had a tagline-- it's a wig for your pet.
我的口号是——这就是你宠物的假发。
Very descriptive. [LAUGHS]
非常形象。[笑声]
Well, you know--
嗯，你知道的——
If you didn't get from the name that it's wigs for pets.
如果名字里没听出来这是宠物假发的话。
Exactly. Because that was always the second-- that was always the followup question, when I said I'm making pet wigs.
正是如此。因为当我跟人说我在做宠物假发时，这总是紧接着的第二个问题。
People would say--
人们会问——
What is a pet wig? It's a wig for your pet. It was almost so shocking to people that they had to have that followup question. So I made it clear.
“什么是宠物假发？”“这就是给你宠物戴的假发。”这太让人震惊了，以至于人们不得不问那个后续问题。所以我把话讲得很清楚。
Three of Leisha's friends were living with her at the time. Their prototypes were always scattered around the living room, and all three friends got really into the project. One made a website. Another took over social media. The third signed her up for conventions, including DragCon.
莉莎当时和三个朋友住在一起。原型总是散落在客厅里，三个朋友都对这个项目很感兴趣。一个做了网站，另一个负责社交媒体，第三个帮她报名了展会，包括“变装皇后”大会。
Leisha was very excited about DragCon. She could show the wigs to people who really know and love wigs and find out if there's any possible market for them. So in preparation, she spent a ton of time building out her booth.
莉莎对那次大会很兴奋。她可以向真正了解并热爱假发的人展示产品，看看是否真的有市场。所以为了筹备，她花了大把时间搭建展位。
It was beautiful. I just want to give it full props. It was a really great-looking booth. It was like a room you walked into. It was all white and clean. I had all the samples on a wall on shelves. And I remember I really wanted it to sort of feel like when you walk into the Apple Store. I wanted it to be clean lines, white walls, very stark. And then I wanted the pictures and the wigs to be the moment. So I wanted it to be top of the line, classic, like so high-- I wanted it to feel high-end.
它很美。我真的很想好好夸夸它。那看起来是个非常棒的展位。就像走进了一个房间，纯白、整洁。所有的样品都陈列在墙上的架子上。我记得我真的很想让它有一种走进苹果专卖店的感觉。我想有清晰的线条、白色的墙壁，非常简约。然后我希望照片和假发成为主角。我希望它是一流的、经典的，那种高端感。
The reaction that people had when they rounded the corner, people lit up in a way I've never been a part of. I've never seen people so happy. [CHUCKLES] I had a line out the door. I'm not going to say they were climbing over each other to get to it, but it was sort of rabid.
人们转过拐角看到展位时的反应，那种闪亮的神情是我从未见过的。我从未见过人们如此开心。[轻笑] 我的展位门口排起了长队。我不会说他们是在争先恐后地抢，但确实非常疯狂。
RuPaul himself even came by the booth. He loved the wigs. And it's then that something shifts for Leisha. Because it's one thing for your sister or your friends to like your idea, but when a stranger, clear-eyed in their total indifference to your well-being, when they tell you your idea is good, you believe it.
甚至连鲁保罗本人都来到了展位，他很喜欢这些假发。就在那时，莉莎的心态发生了转变。因为姐姐或朋友喜欢你的点子是一回事，但当一个陌生人——一个对他人的生计毫不关心的人——告诉你你的点子很好时，你才会相信。
So, riding the high of DragCon, Leisha decides it's time to go big. She sets up an appointment with Walmart. She flies to Bentonville, Arkansas, home of Walmart headquarters. The building is hulking and corporate, with big glass doors and security guards, a far cry from her sunny living room littered with wigs. It's suddenly all feeling very official.
于是，借着展会的东风，莉莎决定玩把大的。她预约了沃尔玛，飞往沃尔玛总部所在的阿肯色州本顿维尔。那栋建筑庞大而有商业气息，有巨大的玻璃门和保安，与她那充满假发的阳光客厅完全不同。一切瞬间感觉非常正式。
It felt-- you know when Annie walks into-- in the musical, when Daddy Warbucks-- you know?
那种感觉——你知道《安妮》音乐剧里，安妮走进沃伯克斯先生家的时候吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
She walks into the house, and she's looking around. Like, almost like that. Like, am I going to like it here?
她走进房子，四处打量。就像那样，我在想：我会喜欢这里吗？
A rep meets her in the lobby, and they walk down this long hallway to his office, passing dozens of identical offices, each filled with other people pitching their products. Leisha said it felt like a factory. Leisha sits down opposite the Walmart guy, setting her bag of wigs next to her on the floor. She takes a deep breath and makes her pitch. She starts as confidently as she feels.
一位代表在大厅迎接她，他们走过一条长长的走廊来到他的办公室，经过几十个同样的办公室，里面塞满了推销产品的人。莉莎说那感觉像个工厂。莉莎坐在那个沃尔玛人对面，把装满假发的包放在脚边，深吸一口气，开始推销。她尽力表现得自信。
One of the first things out of my mouth was, "I'm about to blow your mind."
我嘴里蹦出的第一句话就是：“我保证这会让你大开眼界。”
This, unsurprisingly, was not the first time this guy had heard this. But then Leisha goes in for the hard sell.
不出所料，这人不是第一次听这种话了。但接着莉莎开始全力推销。
I think I talked a lot about the void in the market, the missing piece, the finishing touch to every costume out there, the billions of costumes that are sold every day to pets, to owners, all around the world, yet they're not completed. Because that was a real frustration of mine. It honestly was. It drove me crazy that you couldn't complete a costume.
我聊了很多关于市场空白、缺失的拼图，聊到这是所有服装的画龙点睛之笔。全球每天售出数十亿件宠物服装，却从未完成。因为那真的是我的一个痛点，真的。不能补全服装这件事让我发疯。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
He said, OK, let me see them. And I put them on the desk and presented my pitch deck. And the first thing he said was, great. I'd like to place an order. I think this would be great for Halloween. Let's launch at Halloween.
他说：“好，让我看看。”我把假发放在桌上，展示了我的PPT。他说的第一句话是：“太棒了。我想下一单。我觉得这非常适合万圣节。就在万圣节推出吧。”
Oh, my god.
我的天。
I know. And right away, the questions started coming at me. How much can you make them for? Where are you making these? How are they packaged? How fast can you turn these around? Do you have insurance? Just on and on.
我知道。紧接着，各种问题向我袭来：成本是多少？在哪里生产？怎么包装？交货期多快？你有保险吗？没完没了。
Of all the questions the Walmart guy asked you in your meeting, how many of them did you have answers for, would you say?
在那个会议上，沃尔玛的人问你的所有问题里，你有答案的占多少？
Zero. I had nothing.
零。我什么都没有。
But how did you think that-- how capable were you of fulfilling the Walmart order?
但你当时觉得自己有能力完成沃尔玛的订单吗？
I had no means at the time to fulfill one wig order.
当时我连一份假发订单的能力都没有。
Not even one?
甚至一份都没有？
Yeah. I would have called my sister back up and said, we've got to get cracking. I got some wigs to make. I just had the idea. I had a great idea.
是的。我会打电话给我姐说：“快起来，我们要开干了，有假发要做了。”我只有一个点子。那真的是个好点子。
All at once, the improbability of Leisha's whole scheme caught up to her. Until now, Leisha had been charging full speed ahead, never stopping to consider even basic questions of viability. But now, here was this Walmart guy forcing her to consider, for the first time, the reality of this project, which, frankly, Leisha had no interest in doing.
莉莎整个计划的不可能性瞬间向她袭来。直到现在，莉莎一直在全速前进，从没停下来考虑过任何基本的可行性问题。但现在，这个沃尔玛的人逼着她第一次去思考项目的现实。说实话，莉莎根本不想面对这些。
I remember just wanting to take the wigs and put them back in my safe little bag with my great little ideas and zip it up, and just like, yeah, never mind, you know? You just want to--
我记得当时只想把假发收回那个安全的小袋子里，带着我那些伟大的小点子，把拉链拉上，然后心想：算了吧，你知道吗？你只想——
Protect them from--
保护它们免受——
--forget about it. Yes, from the horror of reality.
——忘掉它。是的，免受现实的恐怖侵袭。
Because that's what he represented to you? He was like reality crashing and ruining the fun?
因为他代表了现实？他就像那个打破一切、毁掉乐趣的现实？
100%. I think he just made me realize it was about to become very unfun very, very fast.
百分之百。我觉得他让我意识到，这一切很快就会变得毫无乐趣可言。
Yeah. And that was the point of it.
是的，重点就在这儿。
That was it.
就是这样。
And with that, Leisha did what so many people fail to do. That little life raft she'd created for herself when things were rough? That log she jumped on? She jumped right back off. She didn't double down. She didn't marry the rebound relationship. Suddenly, she was able to see her pet wigs fever dream for what it was.
于是，莉莎做了很多人做不到的事。她在艰难时刻为自己创造的那根救命稻草？她跳上的那根木头？她又跳了下来。她没有变本加厉。她没有嫁给那个反弹式的关系。突然间，她能看清那场宠物假发的狂热梦境到底是什么了。
It was sort of a strange fantasy bridge that I walked across for a year and a half. Because once it was over, things sort of normalized. And the pieces of my life that I was used to started falling back into place. Yeah, I think I was better. I think I was done.
那就像一座奇怪的幻想桥梁，我走过了一年半。因为一旦结束，事情就开始正常化了。我生活中习惯的部分开始各归各位。是的，我觉得我好多了。我想我结束了。
Leisha tossed the pet wigs into a bin in the shed behind her house, didn't think much about them. And after some time, she threw them away.
莉莎把假发扔进屋后棚子里的桶里，没再多想。过了一段时间，她就把它们全扔了。
How did it feel when Halloween rolled around?
当万圣节到来时，你感觉如何？
The first Halloween, when I would walk through the pet aisles, I'm like, oh, they're still not here. I still don't see a wig.
第一个万圣节，当我走在宠物专区时，我想：噢，它们还是没出现。我还是没看到假发。
Someone should really do something about this.
真的应该有人做点什么。
Yes, someone should, right.
没错，应该有人做，对吧。
But it's not going to be me.
但那个人不会是我。
Exactly.
正是。
Sometimes the reflection you see of yourself, it's just a mirage. There for a moment, then it disappears. And there you are again, the same person you always were. Coming up, how not to explain drugs to your kid. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
有时你在镜子里看到的自己，仅仅是海市蜃楼。在那停留片刻，然后就消失了。接着你又回到了原处，依然是你自己。接下来，如何向孩子解释毒品。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Aviva DeKornfeld, sitting in for Ira Glass. Our show today-- Suddenly, A Mirror. We have stories about people catching surprising reflections of themselves and what they do with that information.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，代班主持阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德。今天的节目主题是“突如其来的镜子”。我们讲述人们捕捉到自己令人惊讶的一面，以及他们如何处理这些信息的故事。
When I was thinking about this theme, I remembered this story about this guy I went to college with. His name is Ari. We went to school just outside Los Angeles, and Ari moved to LA proper after graduation. One afternoon, the summer after he graduated, he was driving around.
我在思考这个主题时，想起了一个大学同学的故事。他叫阿里。我们在洛杉矶郊外上大学，毕业后他搬到了洛杉矶市区。毕业后的那个夏天，一个下午，他正在开车兜风。
I couldn't have been more brains off in this moment. I mean, I was just stuck in traffic, driving along the highway, and was just passively playing the radio.
那时我脑子彻底放空了。我被堵在路上，顺着高速公路开着，被动地听着电台。
Like zoning out, highway hypnosis.
像是放空，高速公路催眠。
Yeah. I was doing a drive like that, had done it a million times kind of thing.
是的，我在做那种开了无数次的驾驶。
He was listening to KCRW, one of the local public radio stations. And--
他听的是KCRW，当地的一家公共广播电台。然后——
The DJ on the radio was just playing a lot of really good music, song after song. It was like, whoa.
DJ放了很多很棒的音乐，一首接一首。简直是：哇。
What kind of songs were they playing?
他们放的是什么样的歌？
I want to say, just a lot of things that were very popular in 2015. So like, indie pop. And I was just like, whoa, who is this DJ? And then they start back announcing the songs, which means after they play a couple songs, they have to do the credits.
我想说，都是2015年特别流行的歌，比如独立流行乐。我就想：哇，这个DJ是谁？然后他们开始报歌名，也就是在放完几首歌后，他们必须报幕。
And I just start having this picture in my head of who they are, like this classic idea of what I understood KCRW DJs to be like, which was a really cool woman who's single, in her late 30s, early 40s, has been on the alt scene for her whole career, has a short pixie cut. I don't know why.
我的脑海里开始勾勒这个人的形象，一种我对KCRW电台DJ的经典认知：一个很酷的单身女性，30多岁到40出头，整个职业生涯都在另类音乐圈，留着精灵短发。我不知道为什么。
So you're really imagining her.
所以你真的在脑补她。
Yeah. Yeah, I just saw it.
是的，我看见了。
So Ari is driving along, feeling like he's found his radio DJ soulmate.
所以阿里一边开车，一边觉得找到了自己的电台DJ灵魂伴侣。
I was like, wow, this person has the exact same music taste as me. This is going to become a staple of my commute, catching their show. And this is going to be just the start of a rich, wonderful, one-sided relationship.
我当时想：哇，这个人跟我有完全相同的音乐品味。这将成为我通勤的主要内容，期待他们的节目。这只是我们那丰富而美好的单方面关系的开始。
And after they back announce everything, they go, you're listening to the Frothy Indie Electronics Show with me, DJ Ari, here on KSPC. And I realized that the voice is me. And I mean, I was just so out of my body, floored because--
在他们报完幕后，她说：“你现在收听的是‘泡沫独立电子秀’，我是你们的DJ阿里，这里是KSPC电台。”我意识到那声音是我自己。我整个人彻底惊呆了，因为——
You're the lady.
你就是那位女士。
Because I'm the lady, exactly. [LAUGHS]
因为我就是那位女士，完全正确。[笑声]
That's so weird.
太怪了。
Yeah. It was like reality broke for a second. How is it possible that I am hearing my own voice?
是的。感觉现实破碎了一秒。我怎么可能听到我自己的声音？
What had happened was this. Ari was not listening to KCRW. He had accidentally tuned to KSPC, our college radio station, where he had DJed as a student. And this set he was listening to was actually a rerun of a show he had done a few months prior.
发生的事情是这样的：阿里根本没在听KCRW。他意外调到了KSPC，我们的校内广播电台，也就是他学生时代当过DJ的地方。他听的这段录音其实是他几个月前做的一期节目的重播。
This mistake he'd made, it was actually a version of a mistake that many, many people had made. You see, anytime Ari is on the phone with someone who doesn't personally know him, they always assume that he's a woman every single time. And that doesn't really bother him. It's not like he finds it insulting or anything. It's more, he just finds it confusing.
他犯的这个错误，其实是很多人都犯过的。你看，阿里每次和不认识他的人通电话时，对方总是默认他是个女人。那对他来说没什么大不了的。他并不觉得被冒犯，更多的是感到困惑。
I don't see it, basically. I just don't hear this is something that I'm going to immediately presume to be a female voice, until I did, in the moment of hearing my voice on the radio.
我基本上看不到，我就是听不出来这会被人立刻判定为女性声音，直到我在听到电台里的自己那一刻。
It's cool that when you finally heard your voice as the rest of the world hears it, you really liked it.
当你最终听到别人耳中你的声音时，你真的很喜欢，这挺酷的。
Oh, hell yeah. I was picturing the coolest person.
噢，太棒了。我把自己想象成最酷的人。
Act Three, There Will Be Questions. This next story is about a dad who catches glimpses of himself in the questions his daughter asks him. The dad is comedian Mike Birbiglia, and he's been traveling around, talking about these questions on stage for over a year now. It's a pretty wide-ranging show. Here's an excerpt.
第三幕，问题不断。接下来的这个故事讲的是一位爸爸在女儿提出的问题中看到了自己的影子。这位爸爸是喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚，他已经巡演了一年多，讲述这些问题。这是一个范围很广的表演，这里是节选。
I'm walking my daughter home from school. And my wife and daughter and I live in Brooklyn, and there's all these smoke shops there. And they have these cutesy names like Blazy Susan--
我接女儿放学回家。我和我妻子、女儿住在布鲁克林，那里到处都是烟店。名字听起来都很可爱，比如“Blazy Susan”——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--and Yes, We Can-nabis.
还有“Yes, We Can-nabis”（可以吸大麻）。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And my daughter Oona looks up. She's nine years old. She looks up at the name of one of these shops, and she goes, Dad, what's The Good Life? And I was like, I don't even know.
我九岁的女儿乌娜抬头看着其中一家店的名字，问我：“爸爸，什么是好生活？”我当时想：我甚至不知道。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
It's not what I'm doing. And but then it was one of those moments where I'm like, oh, I should try to explain drugs as best I can. And I was like, well, some people use drugs, and they make your brain happy, but it's sort of a fake happy. And you don't want to get too happy because then you gotta use more drugs to get it as happy as it was the first time. And then the eighth or ninth time, you're in real trouble. Anyway, Mom and I use them sometimes.
那可不是我在做的事。但那是一瞬间，我想：噢，我应该尽力解释毒品。我就说：好吧，有些人使用毒品，它们会让你的大脑感到快乐，但那是一种虚假的快乐。你不想变得太快乐，因为那样你以后就得用更多的毒品才能达到第一次那种程度的快乐。等到第八或第九次时，你就真的完蛋了。总之，我和妈妈有时候会用。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Not often, mostly when we were younger. Not your age, like three years older than you are now.
不常，大多数时候是在我们年轻的时候。不是你这个年纪，比你现在大三岁的时候。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
But I use prescription drugs. I don't want to, but I have to because I have a serious sleepwalking disorder. The reason I bring up the sleepwalking is that 20 years ago, I get diagnosed with REM sleep behavior disorder, and they put me on Klonopin. And I recently went to a new doctor, and she's looking at my chart. And she goes, you've been on Klonopin for 20 years? And I go, yeah. She goes, all right. That was--
但我用处方药。我不想用，但我不得不，因为我有严重的梦游症。我提梦游是因为20年前我被诊断出患有REM睡眠行为障碍，医生让我服用氯硝西泮。我最近去看了个新医生，她看着我的病历表说：“你服用氯硝西泮20年了？”我说：“是的。”她说：“好吧。”那是——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
That is not what you want to hear when you go to the doctor. I go, are you concerned? She goes, well, do you know the side effects? I go, I don't know. She goes, depression, loss of memory, poor motor skills. I said, oh, I just thought that was my personality.
去看医生时，你最不想听到的就是这句话。我说：“你很担心吗？”她说：“好吧，你知道副作用吗？”我说：“我不知道。”她说：“抑郁、记忆力减退、运动能力低下。”我说：“噢，我一直以为那是我的人格。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
It's a strange moment in one's life when you realize your personality is side effects.
当你意识到你的人格其实就是副作用时，这是人生中一个奇妙的时刻。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Because then I'm just self-conscious about all my daily activities. One thing I do every night before bed is my dosage of Klonopin is 1 and 1/2 milligrams. And so I have to break a pill precisely in half. Yeah, you know who shouldn't have a precision task like that?
因为那样我就对所有的日常活动都变得很自卑。我每晚睡觉前要做的一件事是，我的氯硝西泮剂量是1.5毫克。所以我必须精确地掰开一片药。是的，你知道谁不该做这种精确任务吗？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Someone with poor motor skills. Because inevitably, I break it in half, and there's a pile of Klonopin dust on the sink. And I'm depressed, and I'm crying into the dust. And the tears are merging to form a Klonopin sorbet. And then I lick up--
运动能力低下的人。因为不可避免地，我把它掰开后，水槽上留下一堆氯硝西泮粉末。我很抑郁，对着粉末哭泣。泪水汇聚在一起形成了氯硝西泮果子露。然后我舔掉——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--what I perceive to be a half a milligram, but definitely isn't a half a milligram. So how do I explain that to my daughter?
——我以为是0.5毫克的部分，但绝对不是0.5毫克。那么我该怎么向女儿解释呢？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That's the good life. Yeah, that's what they're saying. There are so many things I feel like I can't explain to my daughter. She's nine years old. And it's just getting harder and harder. Because when they're younger, it sort of doesn't matter. They're an animated bag of rice, and you just gotta make sure they stay animated. And then, even when they're toddlers, it's a lot of layups. What's that? That's an egg. I'm a genius, you know. But--
那就是好生活。没错，这就是他们说的。我觉得有太多事情我无法向女儿解释。她九岁，事情变得越来越难。因为她们小的时候，这其实无关紧要。她们就是一个活泼的饭袋，你只要确保她们一直保持活力就行。然后，即使是蹒跚学步时，也有很多简单问题。“那是什么？”“那是鸡蛋。”我是天才，你知道的。但是——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And my wife doesn't know that much stuff either. She's a poet. I'm a comedian. Together, we're a sculptor.
我妻子也不太懂这些。她是诗人，我是喜剧演员。合在一起，我们就是个雕塑家。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
We just don't know a lot. I mean, and it just started to become very clear to me about a year ago because I get a call from my mom. And she said, Dad was sick this week. And I tried to get him to go to his doctor, but he wouldn't go. And then yesterday, he fell down in the bathtub. And I called 911, and the ambulance took him into the ER. And it turned out he had had a stroke.
我们确实不懂很多。我就是在一年前开始非常清楚地意识到这一点，因为我接到了妈妈的电话。她说：“你爸这周病了。我想让他去看医生，但他不去。昨天他在浴缸里摔倒了。我打了911，救护车把他送进了急诊室。结果是他中风了。”
And I get off the phone, and I'm alone in my bedroom. And then I go into my closet. I'm just sort of organizing things. And I just start crying, alone. And my daughter Oona comes in, and she goes, Dad, what's wrong? And I go, well, Grandpa had a stroke. And she says, Dad, what's a stroke?
我挂了电话，独自待在卧室里。我走进衣橱，整理东西。我开始独自哭泣。我女儿乌娜走进来问：“爸爸，怎么了？”我说：“噢，爷爷中风了。”她说：“爸爸，什么是中风？”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And that's when I realized.
就在那时我意识到了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I can't really explain what a stroke is. I took a swing. I mean, I know the bullet points. I go, it's a brain injury, and there's bleeding in your brain. And then it was a lot of free association after that, you know.
我真的无法解释什么是中风。我试着讲了下。我知道重点。我说：“那是大脑损伤，你大脑里在出血。”然后那之后就全靠自由联想了，你知道的。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I was like, it's your brain. Your brain is bleeding. And I'm not sure where the blood was, but I think it was in the vessels. And they're sort of all in there, you know? And but now, it's just-- it's everywhere.
我说：“那是你的大脑。你的大脑在出血。”我不太确定血在哪里，但我想是在血管里。它们就在那里，你知道的。但现在，它只是——它无处不在。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I think. And maybe ask your mom about that or Grandpa, but not this week, you know? And--
我想。也许去问你妈妈或者爷爷，但不要这周问，你知道的。而且——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
So Oona goes, is Grandpa Vin going to be OK? And I go, I don't know. I'm going to go home tonight. So that night, I drove to Providence, Rhode Island, to the hospital. And I take the elevator up to the eighth floor, to the stroke unit. And I see my dad, and he's just a shell of himself. He can't move half of his body, and he can't really speak.
所以乌娜说：“爷爷维恩会好起来吗？”我说：“我不知道。我今晚要回家。”那天晚上，我开车去了普罗维登斯的医院。我乘电梯到八楼的中风病房。我见到爸爸，他只是空壳一个。他半边身体动不了，也说不出话。
And the neurologist came in, and she goes, Vince, we're going to do a spinal tap. My dad happens to be a retired neurologist. So from the condition he was in, he suggested a type of spinal tap. He goes, guided spinal tap, which is impressive, but also a good example of how controlling my dad is. I'm watching a half-dead neurologist tell a fully alive neurologist--
神经科医生走了进来，说：“文斯，我们要给你做腰椎穿刺。”我爸刚好是退休的神经科医生。从他的状态来看，他建议了一种特定类型的腰椎穿刺。他说：“引导式腰椎穿刺。”这令人印象深刻，但也很好地体现了我爸爸的控制欲。我看着一个半死不活的神经科医生告诉一个活蹦乱跳的神经科医生——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--how to do her job. I mean, that is next-level mansplaining. I mean, that is--
——该怎么做她的工作。那是更高层面的“直男癌解释”。我是说——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
It was devastating seeing my dad in this condition because when I was a kid, I always viewed my dad as larger than life. He was almost like a mythological creature, you know? Just, in a way, I sort of wanted to be my dad because he knew so much stuff. He was a doctor, and in his free time, he got his law degree. Yeah. That's how much he didn't want to be a dad. He was like--
看到我父亲处于那种状态是毁灭性的，因为当我小时候，我总是觉得父亲高大得不可思议。他简直像个神话生物，你知道吗？某种程度上，我甚至想成为我父亲，因为他懂的太多了。他是医生，业余时间还拿到了法学学位。是的。这就是他有多不想当个爸爸。他就像——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[观众笑声，掌声]
He was like, what can I do in these slots of time when I would be parenting? In fairness, we weren't great kids. We always wanted a dad.
他说：“当我应该陪伴子女的时间段里，我能做点什么？”客观地说，我们当时不是乖孩子。我们总是想要个爸爸。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And he wanted another secondary degree. So our goals were at odds.
而他想要个辅助学位。所以我们的目标产生了冲突。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
My dad was a doctor, but I didn't really see him that way, you know. Every once in a while, when I was a kid, strangers would come up to me. They'd be like, (BOSTON ACCENT) your dad is a great doctor!
我爸是医生，但我并没有真正把他看作那样。你知道，小时候，偶尔会有陌生人走过来跟我说：（波士顿口音）你爸爸是个了不起的医生！
And all right, you know? From Worcester, Massachusetts, that's how everyone talks. (BOSTON ACCENT) Your dad is a great doctor.
好吧，你知道的？来自马萨诸塞州伍斯特，大家都这么说话。（波士顿口音）你爸爸是个了不起的医生。
It's like, we don't-- none of us fully understand what our parents do when we're kids. It was rare that I saw my dad as a doctor. I remember a couple times-- I played soccer when I was a kid. I was the goalie. And one time, I dove head-first for the ball. And I got to it. And then the kid on the other team kicked my head-- I know-- with the intensity he had intended for the ball. And I don't know the rest of the story.
就好像我们——没人真正完全了解父母在做什么。我很少见到父亲行医。我记得有几次——我小时候踢足球，我是守门员。有一次，我一头扎下去救球。我拿到了。然后对方的孩子踢到了我的头——我知道——用了他本来打算踢球的力气。我不记得故事的剩下部分了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
But I have been told that I hopped up, and I was like, I'm good. [CHUCKLES] And they took my word for it, and they kept me in the game. And about 15 minutes later, I just wander off the field.
但他们告诉我，我跳了起来，说：“我没事。”[轻笑] 他们信了我的话，让我继续比赛。大约15分钟后，我就晃晃悠悠走出了球场。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼，掌声]
--onto another field.
——走到另一个球场去了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼，掌声]
And my teammates ran over. They go, Mike, are you OK? And I said to them-- and I quote-- I go, what are we even doing here?
我的队友跑过来问：“迈克，你还好吗？”我当时对他们说——原话是——“我们到底在这儿干什么？”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And my dad ran onto the field. And he picked me up, and he carried me off. And he drove me home. And he asked me all the questions that doctors asked their patients. What's your middle name? What are the classes you take at school? And I was like, oh, OK, this is what my dad does.
然后我爸跑进球场。他抱起我，带我离开了。他开车送我回家。他问了我所有医生问病人的问题：你的中间名是什么？你在学校上什么课？我当时心想：噢，好吧，这就是我爸爸做的工作。
And then the other time when it came up is that I went to St. Mary's School for grade school in Shrewsbury, Massachusetts. And every Friday night, we had science club, which is kind of like a mafia front for Catholic school. Like, (BOSTON ACCENT) we believe Jesus turned water into wine, and also, there were dinosaurs, you know. And--
还有一次是在马萨诸塞州什鲁斯伯里的圣玛丽学校读小学时。每个周五晚上我们都有科学俱乐部，那简直是天主教学校的黑帮掩护。比如：（波士顿口音）我们相信耶稣能把水变成酒，而且，恐龙也曾经存在，你知道的。而且——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
So every Friday night, it's like a different parent explaining what science has to do with their job. And one night, it was going to be my dad, and I was so nervous. I was like, what's he going to say? He doesn't know anything about science.
所以每个周五晚上都有不同的家长来解释科学与他们的工作有什么关系。那一晚轮到我爸爸了，我很紧张。我在想：他会说什么？他根本不懂科学。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And he came in, and he brought his medical tools. And he took them out one by one. He explained what each of them does. He took out a three-dimensional model of the brain and explained the hemispheres of the brain. And all these kids came up to me afterwards, and they were like, your dad is wicked smart. You have the smartest dad. I was like, yeah, I do have the smartest dad. But how come he didn't explain any of that stuff to me sooner?
他进来了，带了医疗工具。他一个接一个拿出来演示。他解释了它们各自的用途。他拿出一个三维的大脑模型，解释了大脑半球。之后所有孩子都来跟我说：“你爸爸聪明得吓人。你有最聪明的爸爸。”我说：“是啊，我确实有最聪明的爸爸。可为什么他没早点告诉我这些？”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Because I just didn't see a lot of that, you know? What I would see of my dad was, he'd come home from work around 8 o'clock at night, and he would sit in the corner of the living room and read a war novel and scowl.
因为我没见过很多那一面。我见到的父亲是：他晚上8点左右下班回家，坐在客厅角落里读战争小说，然后愁眉苦脸。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And every now and then, he'd sort of fly off the handle about some little thing. He'd be like, (SHOUTING) where are my goddamn keys?
时不时他会因为一点小事大发雷霆。（大喊）我的该死的钥匙在哪？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I'd be like, we gotta find Dad's keys! I spent my whole life looking for those keys. So we'd look for the keys, and then my mom would just pray, you know. She'd be like, I'm going to say a prayer to St. Anthony. I was seven. I was like, I don't think this is going to work.
我会想：我们得找爸爸的钥匙！我花了这辈子都在找那些钥匙。所以我们去找钥匙，然后我妈妈就祈祷，你知道的。她说：“我要向圣安东尼祈祷。”我当时七岁。我在想：我觉得这不管用。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
We need more concrete tactics to locate the keys. My dad would not like that joke. No, my dad doesn't like a lot of my jokes, but he particularly doesn't like it when they're crude, and then also personal. And he doesn't like political jokes.
我们需要更具体的方法来定位钥匙。我爸不会喜欢那个笑话。不，我爸不喜欢我的很多笑话，但他尤其不喜欢那些低俗又私人的笑话。而且他不爱听政治笑话。
As a matter of fact, when I was in my 20s, I was doing a political joke, and then we ended up having this discussion from it about politics. And it was tense. I was visiting him, and we went for a walk on this wooded path behind his house. And the farther we walked, the more tense it got, to the point where he was just saying mean-spirited things about me. And then I started saying mean-spirited things about him.
事实上，我20多岁时讲了一个政治笑话，结果我们为此讨论了政治。那是很紧张的时刻。我当时去看他，我们在他屋后的林间小路上散步。我们走得越远，气氛就越紧张，以至于他开始说刻薄的话攻击我。然后我开始说刻薄的话攻击他。
And I got back to my car, and I said, bye, Dad. And he didn't say goodbye. He goes, well, you've gone another way. And that was it. And I just drove home. And I just felt so adrift. I thought my whole life, I sort of wanted to be my dad. And at a certain point, I decided I wanted him to be me.
回到车上，我说：“再见，爸爸。”他没说再见。他说：“好吧，你已经走了另一条路了。”就这样。然后我开车回家。我感到如此无助。我想我这一辈子都在试图成为我的父亲。但后来有一天，我决定我希望他成为我。
So I'm with my dad in March at the hospital, and it's devastating. I mean, if you've been with someone who's had a stroke, I mean, it's the worst thing you can possibly imagine. But I will say, if I'm being completely honest, it has calmed him down.
三月份我带着父亲去医院时，情况很糟糕。我是说，如果你陪过中风的人，那是你能想象到的最糟糕的事情。但我必须说，如果诚实地讲，那让他冷静了下来。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Stay with me. Most of the jokes are for you, but a few of them are for me. This is--
听我说完。大多数笑话是讲给你们听的，但有几个是讲给我自己的。这是——
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
This is a coping mechanism. I hope it is for you, too. I mean, most of the time, this is horrific. But then every once in a while, I'm like, where was the stroke when I was five? You know what I mean?
这是一种应对机制。希望对你们也是。我是说，大多数时候这是恐怖的。但偶尔我心想：如果我五岁的时候有那次中风该多好？你们明白我的意思吗？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
When I was a kid, he'd be like, (SHOUTING) where are my goddamn keys? Now he's like, keys. And I'm like, I can't say I don't prefer the latter. It is a little more polite. So I'm with my dad in March at the hospital, and then he can't even really move his face. And so the only way I can even understand his expression is through his eyes. And the expression in his eyes is fear. So how do I explain that to my daughter?
小时候他会说：（大喊）我的该死的钥匙在哪？现在他说：“钥匙。”我心想：不能说我不更喜欢后者。这更有礼貌一点。所以三月份在医院陪他时，他甚至无法移动脸部。所以我理解他表情的唯一方式就是通过他的眼睛。他眼中的表情是恐惧。所以我该怎么向女儿解释呢？
Mike Birbiglia. This was an excerpt from his brand new comedy special, The Good Life. It comes out this week, Monday, the 26th. Go watch it.
迈克·比比利亚。以上是他的全新喜剧专场《好生活》的节选。下周一，26号发行。去看吧。
Act Four, Trouble Afoot. As you've heard many, many times in today's show, how you behave in a crisis, sometimes it shows you who you really are. That can be true even with a very small crisis. Here's David Kestenbaum.
第四幕，麻烦在脚下。正如你们在今天的节目里多次听到的，你在危机时刻的行为，有时会展现出你真正的本性。即使在很小的危机中也是如此。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆报道。
The story starts with a shoe that one day seemed to stop existing. It was a gray and white Adidas, belonging to one Ruby Gans, age 24. Ruby had worn it and its mate to work, like she did just about every day. She's not a person who has a lot of shoes.
故事始于一只某天似乎停止存在的鞋子。那是一只灰白色的阿迪达斯鞋，属于24岁的露比·甘斯。露比就像平时几乎每天一样，穿着它和它的伙伴去上班。她不是有很多鞋的人。
At the end of the day, she switched to her running shoes to go for a run with a friend. The Adidas, she stuck in her car. After the run, she drove home, then reached over to the back seat, where she'd put the shoes.
下班后，她换上跑鞋去和朋友跑步。那双阿迪达斯她塞在了车里。跑步结束后，她开车回家，然后伸手去拿放在后座的鞋子。
And there's only one shoe. And so, I did my best. It was dark at that point. So I did my best to sort through the car and look under the seats.
只有一只鞋。所以我尽力了。那时候天黑了。所以我尽力在车里翻找，在座位底下看了看。
Still, only one shoe. It was weird to lose just one. The next morning, she looks everywhere-- around the car, on the sidewalk. This is in Santa Barbara, California. She texts her parents, who live nearby, "I seem to have lost a sneaker." Her dad texts back, "Have you looked on your feet?" Ruby-- "I have looked on my feet." Dads. She rechecks the car.
依然只有一只鞋。只丢一只鞋太奇怪了。第二天早上，她到处看——车周围，人行道上。这是在加州圣巴巴拉。她给住在附近的父母发短信：“我好像丢了一只运动鞋。”她爸爸回复：“你看看你脚上？”露比：“我看了我脚上。”当爹的。她又检查了一遍车。
I even-- I did the whole deep cleaning thing where you take out all the carpets.
我还——我做了那种深度清洁，把地毯全拿出来了。
Because it has to be somewhere, right?
因为总得在某处，对吧？
Yeah, totally.
是啊，完全是。
Ruby is a science type, works in a lab. So she comes up with a working hypothesis. She figures she had dropped the shoe getting into the car, and the street sweeper had come by and swept it up, which would explain why it was nowhere. Case closed. She kept the one lonely sneaker, just because hope.
露比是理科生，在实验室工作。所以她提出了一个假说。她觉得是上车时鞋子掉了，清道夫刚好经过把它扫走了，这能解释为什么哪里都找不到。结案。她留下了那只孤零零的运动鞋，只是因为心存希望。
It's a new month. I have a new basic pair of shoes that I wear every day. It's a pair of black Doc Martens. And I knew that I had those shoes in the car. I was getting ready for work. I got out to the car, and I could only find one shoe. I was just completely shocked and confused because how could this have happened not once, but twice? I don't know anyone who has ever lost one shoe. And now it's happened to me twice. This just is not possible.
那是新的一月。我每天换了一双基本的鞋。那是双黑色的马丁靴。我知道我把那些鞋放在车里了。准备去上班时，我走到车旁，只找到一只鞋。我感到极其震惊和困惑，因为这种事怎么会发生两次？我不认识任何人丢过一只鞋。现在发生在我身上两次。这简直不可能。
And I looked around, I mean, pretty thoroughly, checked everywhere I could think that a shoe would fit. And there was only one shoe in the car. And I was-- I mean, I would say panicked is too strong, but I was worked up about it. This is not a thing that happens in real life. Where is my shoe?
我四处看了看，我的意思是，相当彻底，检查了我能想到鞋子会掉进的每个地方。车里只有一只鞋。我当时——我的意思是，我觉得“恐慌”有点太过了，但我当时真的很烦。现实生活中不会发生这种事。我的鞋在哪？
I was into Ruby's story. I find losing things to be completely maddening. Objects cannot just disappear. Here's what I want. I want, when you die, for them-- and I don't know who I mean by them-- to tell you where everything you lost over the course of your life actually was when you were looking for it.
我被露比的故事吸引了。我发现丢东西简直令人抓狂。物体不可能就这么凭空消失。这是我的愿望：我希望当你死的时候——我不知道我说的“他们”是指谁——能告诉你，你一生中丢掉的所有东西在你寻找时实际上都在哪儿。
Anyway, Ruby, who is wired similarly, decides she is not going to work until she finds this shoe. Her hunt begins with deduction. She feels sure it was in the car yesterday, which meant it must have fallen out of the car, which feels kind of unlikely now that I say it. Did the shoe hurl itself out somehow?
总之，与露比感同身受的听众们，决定不找到鞋就不去上班。她的搜寻从推理开始。她确定昨天就在车里，这意味着它一定是从车里掉出来的，现在说出来觉得有点不太可能。鞋子是怎么自己跳出去的？
Anyway, she makes a list of every place she had gone the day before. She'd gone to a city office to file a form. She'd gone to a Trader Joe's. And she'd gone to work. So she checks all these places. The parking lot at the city office-- no shoe.
总之，她列出了昨天去过的所有地方。她去市政府办过手续，去过Trader Joe's。然后去了公司。所以她检查了所有这些地方。市政府停车场——没有鞋子。
The Trader Joe's-- actually goes into the Trader Joe's and asks the manager, did any workers find a single shoe in the parking lot? No. She texted the facilities guy at work, who texts her back a laughing face emoji and no, no shoe. She also goes to look at her boyfriend's house, where things took a turn.
Trader Joe's——她甚至进去问经理：“有员工在停车场捡到单只鞋吗？”没有。她给公司的后勤人员发短信，对方回了个笑脸表情和“没有，没鞋”。她还去了男友家查看，事情有了转折。
And I went and I looked all around the house, didn't find the shoe. But I did find his dad, who had showed up. And his dad was like, have you considered that someone's messing with you? And I was like, no, I had not considered that. But you're right, I should.
我四处看了看，没找到鞋。但我遇到了刚好出现的他爸爸。他爸爸说：“你考虑过有人在捉弄你吗？”我说：“不，我没考虑过。但你说得对，我应该考虑。”
He'd just mentioned it in passing, but suddenly, things made a lot more sense. The question was, who was it? It had to be someone who knew about the first shoe and how crazy that had made her, who had then taken the second shoe as a kind of prank. There was a short list of suspects, maybe a friend at work. There are cameras in the parking lot. She could ask the facilities guy to go through them. Or maybe, actually, her boyfriend-- it would have been easy for him to grab her car keys.
他只是顺口一说，但事情突然合理多了。问题是，是谁？那人一定知道第一只鞋的事，知道那把她逼得多疯，然后拿走了第二只作为恶作剧。嫌疑人名单很短，也许是公司的朋友。停车场有摄像头，可以叫后勤去查。或者其实是她男朋友——他拿到她的车钥匙太容易了。
I texted him saying, be straight with me. Are you messing with me? Do you think someone else is somehow messing with me? Is there a way to tell if someone broke into my car? He's a car guy, so.
我给他发短信说：“直说吧。你在捉弄我吗？你觉得有人在以某种方式捉弄我吗？有什么办法能知道我的车是否被破门而入了？他是个懂车的人。”
She waits a minute. He texts her back.
她等了一会儿。他回复了。
"I am not the one hiding your shoes, if that's what you're asking. I don't like pranks, and I wouldn't do that. If someone's doing that, it's not funny to me."
“如果这是你问的，我不是藏你鞋的人。我不喜欢恶作剧，也不会那样做。如果有人在干这事，我觉得一点都不好笑。”
It wasn't funny to her either, but anything was starting to seem possible at this point.
她也觉得不好笑，但此时此刻，任何事都有可能发生。
I was starting to feel a little bit genuinely concerned. It didn't really process at first, but then once I was thinking about it, I realized that would mean somebody is getting into my car, and that makes me pretty uncomfortable. And I'm starting to feel kind of afraid.
我开始感到真心忧虑。起初没什么感觉，但后来我意识到，这意味着有人在进入我的车，这让我很不舒服。我开始感到有点害怕。
Ruby wonders, should I call the police? She drives home from her boyfriend's house, sits on the front steps, when a thought occurs to her. And that thought is, wait, yesterday, didn't I come home for 10 minutes? I did. And didn't I park over there? She gets up, walks over to that spot.
露比想，我应该报警吗？她从男友家开车回家，坐在台阶上，突然想到了一点。那个想法是：等等，昨天我没回家十分钟吗？我回了。而且我没在那停过吗？她起身，走到那个位置。
I looked in the street. I looked in the gutter. It wasn't there. And I was like, ugh, OK, fine. But then, I looked up.
我看了看街道。看了看排水沟。不在那。我想：呃，好吧。但后来，我抬头看了看。
And there, in the tree, was her shoe. I'm kidding. It was a few feet away, on a curb next to someone's yard. It looked like someone had helpfully picked it up and set it off to the side.
那里，在树上……开个玩笑，鞋子就在几英尺外，靠近某人家院子的路缘石上。看起来像是有人好心捡起来放到了边上。
And I was so relieved. I was relieved beyond words to see the shoe sitting there. I took a picture of it.
我感到如释重负。看到鞋子躺在那，我无法言表地感到解脱。我拍了张照。
So many things were put right in that moment. It was confirmation that objects do not suddenly stop existing and disappear. And also, the world was suddenly repopulated in her mind with people who were generally kind and helpful.
那一刻一切都回归正常了。它证实了物体不会突然停止存在并消失。而且，她在心目中再次确信，世界上的人大多是善良而乐于助人的。
It was really nice to swing from thinking that a stranger is trying to break me psychologically to, oh, a stranger picked this up for me.
从觉得有个陌生人在心理上摧毁我，到“噢，有个陌生人为我捡起了这个”，这种反差真的很好。
It was still a little crazy-making that the first missing single shoe was unaccounted for. But then a few days later, she was walking her parents' dog, and it jogged her memory. She'd parked in that very spot she was walking the day she had lost the shoe. It was after the run, but before she went home. She'd just forgotten. And there it was, beside the road, the gray and white Adidas. She was back in the world she had started in.
这依然有点荒谬，因为第一只丢的鞋还是没下落。但几天后，她在遛父母的狗，唤起了记忆。那天丢鞋时，她刚好停在现在走着的那个位置。是在跑步之后，回家之前。她只是忘了。就在路边，那只灰白色的阿迪达斯。她回到了原来的世界。
It's interesting how quickly you went to seriously considering the least likely things, you know?
很有趣，你那么快就开始认真考虑最不可能的事情，对吧？
Yeah. I immediately started thinking about all the crazy-- all the things that people believe and I think are crazy. I'm like, pfft, that could never happen to me. I'm way too smart and logical.
是的。我立刻开始思考所有疯狂的——人们相信的那些我觉得很荒谬的事情。我想：呸，那不可能发生在我身上。我太聪明太理性了。
Actually, it was logic, a kind of logic that led you there, right?
实际上，引导你走到那一步的也是逻辑，某种逻辑，对吧？
Yeah. Maybe I would have thought that I was somehow superior or just-- I don't know. Turns out, I'm not.
是的。也许我会认为自己以某种方式高人一等，或者只是——不知道。结果证明，我不是。
If you are listening to this and feeling a little disappointed, like you were promised a plot twist, something exciting and more dramatic than a story about a woman who had just lost two shoes in a row, because that is what you come to this show for, fair enough. But I am just holding up a mirror to the real world, where sometimes a lost shoe is just a lost shoe.
如果你听完这些感到有点失望，觉得被许诺了情节反转，本以为会有什么比一个女人接连丢了两只鞋更精彩、更戏剧性的故事，因为这就是你们来这节目的目的，那也无可厚非。但我只是在对着真实世界举起一面镜子，在那里，有时丢失的一只鞋仅仅就是丢失的一只鞋。
David Kestenbaum is a senior editor at our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是本节目的高级编辑。
Today's show was produced by me and Tobin Low and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put together our show today include Phia Bennin, Jendayi Bonds, Mike Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Angela Gervasi, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mando, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由我和托宾·洛制作，劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑。今天制作本节目的工作人员包括菲亚·本宁、詹达伊·邦兹、迈克·科米特、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、安吉拉·格瓦西、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·曼多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to Brittany Luse, Kathy Tu, Elly Fishman, Jon Herbert, Alyssa Lowery, Michael Burgin, Sheila Maloney, Ora DeKornfeld, Nathan Englander, Katie Rhodes, Chris Thompson, and John Skidmore. Our website is thisamericanlife.org.
我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。特别感谢布列塔尼·卢斯、凯西·图、艾莉·菲什曼、乔恩·赫伯特、阿丽莎·洛厄里、迈克尔·伯金、希拉·马洛尼、奥拉·德科恩菲尔德、内森·英格兰德、凯蒂·罗兹、克里斯·汤普森和约翰·斯基德莫尔。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。
I know this is the spot where Ira mentions This American Life Partners and all the perks you can get, like bonus episodes. I did one a couple of months ago in which Ira called me, quote, "mean and eye-rolly." So if you want to hear that, head on over.
我知道这是艾拉提到“《美国生活》合伙人”以及你们能获得所有福利（比如赠送剧集）的地方。我几个月前做过一期，艾拉在里面称我为“刻薄且喜欢翻白眼的人”。所以如果你想听那个，就过来看看吧。
But really, all the bonus episodes are so good and funny and super different from the stuff you normally hear on our show. Ira cries in one, which is kind of cool. So to hear those episodes, and more importantly, to help us keep making the show, subscribe at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
但说真的，所有的赠送剧集都很好、很有趣，和你平时在节目里听到的内容非常不同。艾拉在其中一期里哭了，这挺酷的。所以为了收听这些剧集，更重要的是，为了帮助我们继续制作节目，请在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners注册。该链接也在节目说明中。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, big dog Ira Glass. He's back on the dating scene and has this new approach where he's trying to be radically honest about what he needs from a partner. And so if the first date goes well, he sits the person down before the end of the night and lets them know--
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往的老板，“大狗”艾拉·格拉斯。他回到了约会圈，并有了一种新方法，即他试图诚实面对自己从伴侣那里需要什么。如果第一次约会很顺利，他会在深夜结束前找那个人坐下来，让对方知道——
This is going to be just the start of a rich, wonderful, one-sided relationship.
“这只是那丰富而美好的单方面关系的开始。”
I'm Aviva DeKornfeld. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德。艾拉下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。